you know I think what inspires me is the
is the everyday activist there's a girl
six-year-old Mackenzie Steiner um her
mom called me and she said hey I'd like
you to come down and talk with Mackenzie
and her friends and I'm like well I
don't do beat you know I don't do
birthday parties you know who is this
and she's like my daughter six years old
and she's handwriting invitations to her
friends for beach cleanups and I went
down there and I podcasted with
Mackenzie I'm sitting there I've kids
and but I was sitting there listening to
Mackenzie I'm like Mackenzie why are you
an environmentalist and she was just
like I have no idea what you're talking
about that I don't even know what that
is and I'm like well it's just someone
who loves nature she's like yeah I'm
absolutely that so why she's like you
know looking at me strange and she's
like birds should just have clean air
fish should have clean water you know
these are just simple things you know
like like I'm the idiot those we have
those stories every single day a woman
last night at one in the morning I got
an email from a woman in an Arizona
Correctional Institution waxing on
lyrically about the values of surfrider
foundation she actually she's not
prisoner she works in the in a state-run
facility and she was talking about
moving some of her money over you know
an automatic withdrawal over two groups
that she supports and surf rider was one
but hearing her talk about that it's
just that's absolutely the joy of every
single day